I think people are going to because
there's so much more information and
because there is so much more access
everybody's starting to get this a DD
thing you know attention spans are
getting much shorter and and I think
it's it requires of the individual and a
sort of a talent and the skill to filter
to really with all the information that
you see to just very quickly understand
and grasp whether this information is
relevant for you or not and so I think I
think that's probably one of one of one
of the changes because I mean everything
is getting small it's getting more
mobile that's getting more real-time so
so it just really depends on what people
make of the opportunity